thanks for joining us here at noon i'm
heather mills right now some new details
about the massive new year's eve
fireworks show coming back to the las
vegas strip the theme this year
deuces wild hector mejia joining us live
from the fashion show mall on the strip
hector that announcement just made a
short time ago
that's right in this massive fireworks
spectacular finally coming back after a
one-year hiatus it will be a eight
minute eight minute long show no matter
where you go along the las vegas strip
we're told you'll get a great seat and
be able to watch the fireworks pop in
the sky and pyro technicians will be
firing off from eight rooftop properties
from the strat in the north all the way
down to the mgm grand new you this year
resorts world the announcement was made
at 11 o'clock this morning bringing out
elected officials as well as the las
vegas convention and visitors authority
according to fireworks by grucci it'll
be an eight-minute thrilling heart
pounding performance they're
coordinating with multiple agencies to
make it happen this year
we're just incredibly happy to be able
to do that you know especially after a
year off you know it's just it's tough i
mean it hurt everybody so now we want to
get back and say hey we're back
[Music]
on december 27th more than 60 pyro
technicians plus an army of about 70
security staff members will install the
fireworks over the course of five days
the display we're told is a huge
economic driver usually brings in around
300 000 people to the las vegas strip to
watch the show and during a presentation
the lvc va also played a video talking
about looking back at 2021 and during
the pandemic how it was a meaningful
year as business was returning reporting
live from fashion show hector mejia live
local now